multitudes se reúnen en París para ver
cómo la Torre Eiffel se ilumina con los
colores de la bandera ucraniana
este gesto simbólico indica al mundo
entero que apoyamos a Ucrania que
Ucrania ganará y que celebraremos juntos
esta Victoria
al igual que en ciudades como riga
Belgrado y sidney Bruselas también
acogió activistas con banderas
ucranianas frente a la Unión Europea en
Lisboa el parlamento se iluminó de azul
y amarillo un homenaje silencioso a
Ucrania mientras en Londres el Primer
Ministro británico
de silencio en Downey Street junto al
embajador ucraniano y funcionarios del
gobierno
en las calles londinenses la gente se
reunió para escuchar música y discursos
la actriz Helen mirren recitó un poema
mientras llama la cantante ucraniana
ganadora de eurovisión en 2016 actuaba
para cientos de londinenses es
originaria de crimea la Península
ucraniana anexionada por Rusia en 2014
estamos luchando por nuestros derechos a
vivir en nuestro hogar en el siglo XXI
luchamos por nuestro derecho a hablar en
nuestro idioma por la Libertad
en Nueva York se celebró una vigilia con
velas frente al consulado ruso
cizaron banderas ucranianas junto con
pancartas contra Putin
aprendimos que en tiempos de guerra en
los horribles momentos en los que un
enemigo ataca
podemos olvidar nuestras diferencias y
unirnos
ucranianos y rusos reunidos aquí un
mensaje de unidad en tiempos de guerra